Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P Here is a
really funny voicemail. I have a new nickname. My
new nickname is Book Boy, and I have to tell you
it's not really an insult. I wish more people
read books. I kind of like this. Take a listen.
Speaker 7: Hey, good boy, what's going down?
Have you figured out street smarts yet?
Right? And still, I have a question for
you, please. What is your interpretation
of your understanding of democracy? Because
I'm getting different answers from everybody.
Speaker 1: I mean, in a super simple way, I would
say democracy is when the will of the people is.
What is able to be expressed and act and is acted
on by our representatives? I mean, you know, a
lot of these right wingers love to have us define
terms like when I was on with Jesse Lee Peterson,
he said, What is love? What is a man? And
I told him, I don't know. I don't really do
dictionary definitions. But I guess in
some way it's the a system in which the
desires of the people are freely expressed
and then acted on by our elected officials.
I don't know. It's very maybe that's quaint.
Speaker 7: Do you understand what democracy is
and what the farm is supposed to be
going on with that? I don't think so.
I don't think so. The government does not run
this country, big business does. OK. That's why
they legalize lobbyists and
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, he's not wrong about
the outsized influence of big business, for sure.
Speaker 7: He would pay for any congressman
or any senator they want to. Do you honestly think
that we're being served as a country through this
government? And if you do, and you're naive.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing. This guy is
making it about this particular government.
The systemic problems with American government
haven't changed because Biden won and
Trump lost, and I'm right there with them.
But the idea that there's something particularly
pernicious about the Biden administration now,
there's no evidence for that whatsoever. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. We will
talk about a court ordering actor Jussie Smollett
released from jail during his appeal. We will talk
about the new hundred and twenty five million
dollar demand from former CNN host Chris Cuomo.
He says he was wrongfully terminated. We will talk
about that. And lastly, Netflix is testing a new
feature to fight against password sharing. Yeah,
we will talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at Join
Pacman dot com. I'll see you back.